mental health is the core of everything  school is just a stepping stone for you  to get to the  end goal which is to become  a professional who's gonna contribute to  the betterment of society and  you can't have a positive influence on  other people  or become a mentor to them if you're not  healthy  in here and mental health is just  it's just like physical health it's  something that you have to practice  every single day otherwise you'll get  burnt out  so start getting in the habit of taking  a little bit of time for yourself  preferably doing something that's off  the screen  this reflection can actually help you  with your workflow as well  i think stepping back to think about  your struggles and  inefficiencies can be a really good  thing to incorporate into your daily  lifestyle